what you're about to hear are six
seconds that change the course of music
history from NWA to Skrillex
from David Bowie to countless Drum &
Bass songs this four-bar drum solo is
possibly the most sampled piece of
recorded music ever this is the Amen
break in 1969 funk soul band the
Winston's released a single called color
him father the b-side of that record was
a groovy horn driven rendition of a
traditional gospel song called Amen
brother at 1 minute and 25 seconds
drummer GC Coleman takes a solo color
him father would win a Grammy Award for
Best R&B song but Amen brother would
remain nothing more than a b-side for
years
enter break beat Lou all right so from
the top Luis Flores aka baby Lou Bronx
DJ since 1974 Lou and his late partner
Lenny Roberts started making
compilations for DJ's called ultimate
breaks and beats my role mainly was to
help him select the records and then I
started becoming the editor and the
recording engineer for these particular
records the first ultimate breaks and
beats included a half dozen tracks
including of course amen brother
the drum break is part one of the most
organic larger-than-life big presence
style of drums the way the drums are
toom the way they are played the way the
hi-hat is going is real soft but real
rhythmic and the way the kick is head is
hard you like a heavy leg the snares
snapping in your face there's so many
depths to this particular drag there's
nothing else like it as young DJ's
became producers they slowed down the
Amen break and used it as the foundation
in early hip hop songs notably nwaz
Straight Outta Compton
NWA Straight Outta Compton is straight
out
amen brother you really got the
excitement of and the message director
was sending I don't think any other drum
break could have made it the way it was
throughout the 90s the influence of the
Amen break continued to spread the
sample became a defining element to drum
and bass and jungle music like this
track by English DJ Dillinger according
to the online database who sampled by
the end of 2018 the break has appeared
in over 3000 songs
cropping up in little wonder by David
Bowie I lists by Slipknot and
contemporary electronic acts like
Skrillex - think of the impact that has
had in multiple genres is incredible we
had no idea that the sampling craze was
gonna become what it has even though we
didn't release CDs about the impact of
automation beats having plugged people
to create CDs as bootlegs
full cover credits and everything behind
it after putting out 25 volumes of
ultimate breaks and beats Lew saw the
industry changing and decided to walk
away from his music career but the
legacy of ultimate breaks and beats
remained and in 2009 people wanted to
put a face to the album's creators and
Lew was coaxed out of retirement
I had no idea of the appreciation for
the compilation had become an
appreciation for Lenny and myself then
when they found out I was a DJ also than
ever I also come back in DJ there's been
a snowball effect of the appreciation
for what we contributed to the culture
it is humbling it is mind-boggling and
it brings a certain amount of pride that
we were able to become a part of music
history in that sense
[Music]